well in my case of course if you've been
to prison you wonder how many people
will stand by you when you come out and
the answer is that my champagne and
Shepherds pipe artists that I hold each
year at which 200 are invited on each
night we lost eight people out of 200 at
a four hundred people out of 400 and the
British people have been very responsive
and very fair I was on a podcast thing
the other day where I was answering
questions on emails and we had 57
questions to answer and 55 were kind one
was not so good and one was bad but
that's very much the British people's
attitude they're very generous raised
and up to be fair i found the Americans
the same way